Hello, I'm Berna Lidero with VOA 60 America for January 16th.
A report by the Senate Intelligence Committee...
...says the 2012 assault on the American diplomatic compound in Benghazi, Libya was preventable.
Four Americans, including the US ambassador, were killed in the assault.
The report blames the State Department for failing to bolster the compound's security...
...in response to intelligence about the growing security crisis around Benghazi.
When asked about the report, State Department spokeswoman Marie Harf told reporters...
...there were no specific intelligence warnings about an impending attack.
The House of Representatives has approved a 1.1 trillion dollar budget for the 2014 fiscal year,...
...avoiding another government shutdown.
The bill is expected to pass the Senate this week.
Finally, Oscar nomination time.
American Hustle and Gravity lead the way with ten nominations each, including best picture.
The 86th Academy Awards will be held on March 2nd.
That's all for today.
Thanks for watching.